HILLARY CLINTON, AND NOT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S TEAM.
NEW YORK IS MONICA CROWLEY, A
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE LONDON
CENTER FOR POLICY RESEARCH.
WITH ME HERE IN WASHINGTON IS
ATTORNEY ALAN.
YOU HEARD MY TAKE CARE.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE
>> I THINK EVERY BUDDY IS
ACCOUNTABLE.
I THINK YOUR CONCERNS ARE ABOUT
THE INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATING IN
THE ACTUAL INVESTIGATION, WHICH
DOESN'T MEAN THE INVESTIGATION
YET, SO WHY THE BIG CONCERN?
IF YOU ARE NOT GUILTY OF A CRIME
THEN WHY IS THERE A PROBLEM WITH
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS?
>> Laura: MY CONCERN IS WHEN
YOU POPULATE YOUR INVESTIGATIVE
TEAM WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
ACTIVELY WERE ENGAGED IN THE
HILLARY EMAIL INVESTIGATION AND
ACTUALLY HELPED EDIT COMEY'S
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
NONINDICTMENT INDICTMENT, THAT
THAT KIND OF ENTANGLEMENT IS THE
MERE APPEARANCE OF THE CONFLICT
OF INTEREST IS NOT WHAT YOU WANT
CASE THIS SERIOUS IS ENOUGH TO
SHAKE THE CREDIBILITY OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND I'M NOT SAYING
THAT EVERYONE ON THE TEAM IS
BAD, I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
BUT IF THE SHOE WERE ON THE
OTHER FOOT AND HILLARY CLINTON
WERE BEING INVESTIGATED BY A
BUNCH OF TRUMP LOYALISTS WHO HAD
WRITTEN TERRIBLE THINGS ABOUT
HILLARY AND COULDN'T STAND
WOULD BE ON THEIR SHOW GOING
THERE.
>> MAY BE HILLARY CLINTON WAS A
SCAPEGOAT FOR SOME TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, BUT THIS IS JUST A
BUNCH OF STORIES ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF PAPERWORK
THEY CAN ALSO HANDLE THIS.
THIS IS WHAT THEIR DUTY IS AS
THE FACT THAT THEY WORKED ON
PRIOR CASES HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS CASE.
IF THEY ARE LOOKING FOR THE
FACTS AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
GOING AFTER.
>> Laura: YOU THINK IT'S OKAY
FOR PARTISANS TO BE WORKING ON
AN INVESTIGATION WHEN THEY WERE
LOYALIST TO THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION AND WORKED ON THE
EXONERATION OF HILLARY CLINTON?
IF THE SHORE OF THE OTHER FOOT.
>> I WOULD ASK THE
PROFESSIONALS.
>> Laura: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THEY ARE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT PERFECT.
THE ONLY PERSON FOR DOMINIC
PERFECT TO WALK THE FACE OF THE
EARTH, JESUS CHRIST.
AN APPARENT CONFLICT OR AN
APPEARANCE OF A CONFLICT IN A
CASE LIKE THIS IS NOT WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO.
BOB MUELLER IS THE SMARTEST
PERSON AROUND, LIKE HE IS THE
SMARTEST GUY WHO EVER LIVED
APPARENTLY, BUT HE HAD NO
PROBLEM BRINGING IN THESE PEOPLE
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN BE
INDEPENDENT IN YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS IF YOU HATE HIM AS MUCH
AS THEY DID.
GOT TO GET YOU IN ON THIS.
ALAN SAYS THEY ARE PROFESSIONALS
INVESTIGATION AND THE DEMOCRATS
SAY THIS IS MUCH ADO ABOUT
NOTHING.
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION THAT
NEEDS TO REACH ITS CONCLUSION
AND EVERYBODY IS THROWING A
BUNCH OF PIXIE DUST UP AND THEY
ARE HOPING IT GOES AWAY.
>> IT MAY IN FACT BE TRUE THAT
THIS ENTIRE INVESTIGATION WAS
PREDICATED ON A LIE ABOUT
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, WHICH WAS
ESSENTIALLY A FRAME OF
DONALD TRUMP.
IF THESE PEOPLE NEVER EXPECTED
HIM TO WIN.
THEY EXPECTED HILLARY CLINTON TO
WIN SO ALL OF THEIR POSSIBLY
CRIMINAL AND UNETHICAL
SHENANIGANS THROUGHOUT THE
CAMPAIGN TO TORPEDO DONALD TRUMP
AND THEN ONCE HE WAS ELECTED,
OF THAT EVIDENCE WOULD GO AWAY.
PRESIDENT.
THAT EVIDENCE IS BEING UNCOVERED
LEFT AND RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE MUELLER
TEAM, THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
CORRUPTED ACCORDING TO THE
EVIDENCE AS WE KNOW IT SO FAR,
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE SO
FRANTICALLY TRYING TO DEFLECT
AND LIE ABOUT NOT JUST WITH
DATED, BUT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
AS WELL.
>> Laura: I WANT YOU GUYS TO
BOTH LISTEN TO SOMETHING THAT
ADAM SCHIFF, ALSO ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE, WHAT HE SET ABOUT
THIS CONCERN ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATORS.
>> WHY WOULD YOU VOTE TO NOT
HAVE --
>> THE POINT WAS THEY DIDN'T
CARE WHAT WAS IN THE UNDERLYING
DOCUMENTS.
THEY WANTED TO MAKE A POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
THEY WANTED TO DO WHAT THEY
>> Laura: WANT TO, THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE WANTING THOSE PAGES,
THE SYNOPSIS, RELEASED TO THE
PUBLIC.
THEY JUST WANT TO FEED THE
BEAST, THEY WANT TO FEED FOX.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO DISCREDIT
THE CHAIRMAN, TRYING TO
DISCREDIT THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE EXPOSING A LOT OF THIS
CORRUPTION AND A LOT OF THIS
EVIDENCE.
I CAN TELL YOU TONIGHT, LAURA,
BASED ON ONE OF MY SOURCES, THAT
WE WILL SEE ALL OF THESE
DOCUMENTS.
>> I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHY ARE WE NOT SEEING IT NOW?
WHY DO WE NEED TO WAIT TO SEE
IT?
THE COMMITTEE --
>> WE WILL SEE THEM.
>> I THINK THE PROCESS SHOULD BE
BIPARTISAN BECAUSE THE CONCERT
IS BIPARTISAN SO WHY HAS ONLY
PART OF THE COMMITTEE ALREADY
SEEN THE MEMO AND THE REST
VETTED THE MEMO WITH ITS REGARDS
TO NATIONAL SECURITY, A PRIMARY
ISSUE OF ALL THIS IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A VERY
IN THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
WHEN THEY DO TALK ABOUT THOSE
WHO ARE ATTACKING THEIR
INVESTIGATION ARE TRYING TO
DISCREDIT THEIR FBI AND THE DOJ
AND ATTACKING THE INSTITUTIONS
DOJ DISCREDIT IN THEMSELVES.
>> WHERE TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS.
>> THE ONE THING FROM ALL OF
PEOPLE FREELANCED ALL OF THIS
THAN ANYTHING --
>> ARE NOT SURE WHY WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT BARACK OBAMA
TONIGHT.
>> Laura: WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A CHANCE TO
ROOM TO READ THIS MEMO.
ONLY I THINK A FEW HAVE.
I'M ALWAYS FOR MORE SUNSHINE,
MORE TRANSPARENCY.
LET'S SEE WHAT IT IS.
IT MAY MAYBE THE REPUBLICANS ARE
OVER BLOWING IT.
MAYBE IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT FOR
MYSELF.
PEOPLE SEEM REALLY HOT AND